um beijo tchau meu amor é o pé no
patamar do topo porque tô tucana passou
a tarde no meio tempo você pede a iara
que a gente não tá tudo com vocês eu
estou muito pesado porque a mulher
porque eu adotei esta belezinha aqui e
da oi da da oi galera do youtube dá num
não não
galera eu então meu novo integrante e
amigo e integrante dessa casa wesley
safadão esse é seu natal é essa falta
então é este o plantão era o seguinte
olha no facebook eu vi começou a
aparecer um alto índice de nossa
atmosfera onde mais pelo brasil 10 que
legal acostumaram é vai ser no brasil de
modo leve porque eu fico puto porque tem
um raio tem um ódio de quando a pessoa
fala foi mulher dando à sabendo o que
foi negado não vai ter show da casa
leite amanhã e depois e aí mulher vai
mulher não vou não
mas aí tenho ódio quando a pessoa parece
que recebe a profissão de ter que
distribuir o evento vai acontecer sem
que ela não vai porque eu tô vendo cada
pessoa possa negócio de moda no facebook
882 a pessoa não vai no show de bruno e
marrone e dizer que vai fazer mal nenhum
e não vai no show do pepê e neném da pm
nem natal conta com uma parte maior led
vocês a entrada no negócio desses é o
que é 40 inteira estudante paga meia
aniversário e não paga nada melhor para
dar desconto até meia noite entre a
energia agora vou passar não já
compreendem a nama vai vender um carro
estamos comprando ingresso pra mim a não
já estou vendo meu corpo no modo sexual
do sexo anal para poder ir aí sim é você
ó homem além do brasil o lê
onde marlene se bem que ele não deve
esperar muito do evento de sendo feito
no brasil e no brasil não seja a atração
sou muito legal aberto é quem pega o
franca também de rua depois vem e me
seguir regional abelha
ei ei mas obra não ficar pronta até o
dia do evento vamos dizer que o chão vai
ser de barro entre ivete sangalo que
tanto era poeira ou não espera muita
coisa a galera no último final de semana
fez um show em fortaleza e foi muito
muito muito [ __ ]
háháhá
ó e foi presidente tarde presente ao
topo da capa ea gente um quadro gente
olha eu ea minha fã de gente que coisa
linda
um quadro jeitão bota meus fãs melhor
essa bola e da quad ana arraes a 1 da
área está também a e dia 14 de setembro
tem em são luís no maranhão
quando abri a venda de ingressos já vou
postar no facebook o twitter no estádio
não é nós e é nós
muito obrigado que foi meu deus o que é
de uma leve
não não não
valeu galera clique no botão que você
tiver gostado comenta alguma coisa valeu
é na e perto de nós